[موسيقى]
نحتاج إلى طائرات بدون طيار يمكنها
فعل ما تريده بدقة للقيام
بذلك في هذه الحالة ، نحن
نحاول بدقة اتباع مسار في ظروف الجناح المختلفة ،
فنحن نتكيف بسرعة فائقة ، ونفعل ذلك
مثل 50 هرتز ، وهذا يعني أننا  قم بتكييف
النموذج كل 20 مللي ثانية ،
لذلك يُطلق على هذا اسم
سيارة الإسعاف الطائرة المستقلة ، وبفضل
طريقة التحكم القائمة على الذبابة العصبية ، يمكننا بشكل أساسي
إرسال سيارة الإسعاف الطائرة هذه
لإسعاف الركاب المصابين من
حادث مروري ولكن يمكننا التأكد من
أن هذه الطائرة بدون طيار تحلق بشكل مستقل
يمكن لسيارة الإسعاف أن تهبط في أي
ظروف جوية بسبب أسلوب الطيران العصبي لدينا
[موسيقى]
يمكننا على الأرجح تطوير الطائرة
التي يمكن أن تجعل
الرحلة الجوية أكثر سلاسة
وراحة وما إلى ذلك لأنها يمكن
أن تتعامل مع
ظروف الرياح المضطربة هذه بشكل أفضل
[موسيقى
] لفترة طويلة  - مهمة المدى هي أننا نريد
تعميم هذه التقنية ليس فقط على
التربيعات على السيارات الطائرة إلى أي منطقة
روبوت بحيث يمكنهم الإعجاب بدقة
بأمان  مثل القيام بمهام معقدة
[موسيقى]